il est là ce soir c'est parti c'est
le shanghai shenzhen
métrage incroyable valeur unique leur
mère que je demande à fond
[Applaudissements]
l'indic de la rédaction est aussi arrivé
donc quelques minutes ça va cirer le
banc sarthois mais ça va super eh oui
vous avez passé une semaine très bien et
toi moi oui super bon j'ai vu vous avez
fait un petit tour des studios de radio
cette semaine un mois c'est vrai on va
en parler juste après mais avant on va
voir ce qui s'est passé dans les
matinales radio avec nos amis les
politiques c'est le gauche à droite
éric ciotti candidat des républicains
arrêtées dans tout les matinales cette
semaine et ce qui est bien avec lui
c'est comment y varie son discours je
suis profondément convaincu au fond
dément convaincu je suis convaincu que
seul un candidat issu la droite et lui
dit qu'elle pourra pas très marrant je
sais pas si mes propositions sont
radicales mais je crois en tout cas
qu'il faut couper le robinet laitiers
elizabeth martichoux a tout tenté pour
démoraliser nicolas dupont aignan mais
il a bien gardé la tête haute le nyko
quand avec vous très bien je vous
demande ça parce que vous êtes coincé
entre marine le pen et eric zemmour à 2
% dans les sondages elle est responsable
de chez vous qui sont partis chez le dit
zemmour ça peut très bien
au ballon noah j'ai trouvé le mec le
plus intimiste du monde arnaud
montebourg pour qui tu roules quoi qu'il
arrive qu'une question les parrainages
vous en êtes où ben écoutez ça va très
bien les mères viennent à dépasser 150
c'est pas mal hein j'ai commencé il ya
20 jours
est à 3% c'est mieux que zéro
et toujours sur et pl à lyon turin à
part aussi bruno le maire mais plutôt
bruno le fic
nous avons considérablement durci notre
arsenal contre la fraude fiscale je le
dis ne vous amusez pas à frauder parce
qu'en général vous êtes vite rattrapé
par la patrouille mise en place d'une
task force je serai intraitable avec
ceux qui ont triché avec lui
[Musique]
mais qui garde le moral 3
j'adorais ça très drôle on a droit à une
petite question est ce que vous avez en
sons du moment un son qui vous fait
kiffer ou un artiste dadjo n'en a pas
besoin bon en tout cas est ce qu'ils
font ce que je quitte bien en tête la
défense où elle est géniale moi si vous
vous demandez si jean jacques bourdin
s'y connaît tout autant que vous en
musique vous avez la réponse
des chefs de gouvernement je sais pas
moi la chanteuse shaqiri
si xavier bertrand vient du nord et du
sud aurillac aller d'expression des
quatre coins de la france
une fois et d'immigrants dit chez nous
commente et celle aux tubes mais aussi
au volant mais au bout d'un moment ça je
suis pas non plus un perdreau de l'année
donc on va avoir des besoins de plus en
plus important et on veut diminuer la
part du nucléaire dans des fan house
koala eric zemmour était dans les
grandes gueules de rmc ils étaient tous
gentils tout cas mais avait même une
petite envie de déconner le z eric
bonjour bonjour eric zemmour vous avez
pris votre décision j'ai pris ma
décision à propos de quoi
et de 2022
ou en vrai ça va durer longtemps il a
juste suffi de cinq minutes pour que ça
parte en le coup
moi je ne parlais pas sur moi écoutez
moi je vis pendant que vous parlez vais
pas la voix s'élève la voix pour être
président fouad car je m'en fous
alors cyril juste avant qu'on soit la
météo des réseaux on en a parlé cette
semaine dans les matinales il y avait
beaucoup de candidats et de
personnalités mais l'invité plus
convoité mettez-vous à c'est une panique
en souriant
je peux pas le faire longtemps vous
allez voir j'ai gardé les meilleurs
moments bon par contre je me suis pas
fait chier pour trouver le nom il ya
baba c'était le matin c'est le ba-ba
matin à barbe merci
des bras cassés
henin jouera pauline bon jour serena
bourgeois du coup vous étiez sur votre
lancée vous avez vraiment dit bonjour à
tout le monde bonjour stéphane bonjour
bonjour céline bonjour mobile vous étiez
donc dans rtl matin chez yves calvi et
apparemment vous avez été un peu surpris
de la déco du studio rtl matin indique
yves calvi
il est 7h45 excellente journée la piste
comme sur les dons soit en syrie
aussi à la maison sur ces news avec
pascal co mais on a senti que pascal
avait besoin de vous leur assure y est
quand même un peu tout ça votre
habillement tous vouloir venir sur votre
plateau côté on dit souvent dans vos
clients avec vous quand même aussi vous
êtes vous une star non pas du tout
pressé non mais bon en fait vous ne
faites un peu de concurrence
cette semaine c'était le cirill de
l'académie française alors vous écoutant
j'ai appris plein de nouveaux looks
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le candidat qui commençaient à frémir il
a toujours un langage extrêmement châtié
ils sont venus à ça ça s'invective et
qu'ils avaient envie de faire une joute
verbale il faut arrêter aussi dans les
cornes et reese efforts étaient dire à
ces gens là c'est des merlus moi je me
suis ratée au passage sur skyrock c'est
un autre débat comme cette agglo et je
sais de la cei
de faire une joute verbale
extrêmement châtié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'est passé sur les réseaux ça on adore
ah ouais vous allez regarder un petit
peu les réseaux cette semaine j'arrête
pas à moi je vous ai regardé je vous ai
gardé les meilleurs moments et chez vous
attendait ça avec impatience peut-être
un peu plus que l'automate paddle ou
quand même pas quand même pas quand même
c'est là d'ailleurs c'est la météo des
réseaux
à demain dans nord un gars a posé une
question existentielle à son pote mais
il est où le deuxième club deuxième
c'est qu'il donnait
3 j'ai découvert que les chiens étaient
super folie là bas
[Musique]
bon ça c'est à troyes mais par contre
quand les chiens ils prennent un peu la
confiance retrouvée bloquée sellal
zut et justement signé ce quartier ni
c'était tout cannes jusqu'à ce que seven
plaza débarquent pour une visite
oui j'y tiens saint briac pas besoin de
prendre des cours de self défense si
vous tombez face à ce mec
et amis nantais attention quand vous
cherchez l'amour sur les api de
rencontre il peut y avoir des surprises
[Musique]
qui connaissent que
je le disais
[Applaudissements]